two doses of vaccine are simply not
enough get boosted now
booster jabs could provide much needed
protection against the new covid variant
and prevent further restrictions as we
head into the festive period
if the government just sort of stuck its
head in the sand and said let's just
wait and see what happens let's wait for
the death to happen by then it would be
too late we're opening up the booster to
every adult over 18 who has had a second
dose of the vaccine at least three
months ago this accelerated booster
campaign will come at a cost with the
nhs saying that some other health
appointments may be delayed and in the
winter months when extra pressures are
already putting strain on the nhs is it
even achievable
[Music]
the data tells us we're more likely to
get the new omicron variant and more
likely to pass it on to others even if
we've been double jabbed but it also
seems less likely to cause serious
illness in a number of
cases i mean these high numbers we are
not seeing it dead so that's that's a
big consolation
reasons to be cheerful you might think
but as ever with this virus there is a
great deal we do not know
none of the laboratory studies although
they're helpful actually
provide
absolute proof and for that we'll need
to see what happens in the real world
and that'll be a few weeks away yet
[Music]
more than 50 million people in the uk
have been double vaccinated and 23
million had had a booster before the
prime minister's call to accelerate the
program
scientists advising the government say
that over time the protection offered by
two jabs wanes hence the call for a
top-up
[Music]
boris johnson says he's asking those on
the front line for another extraordinary
effort he plans to deploy 750 military
personnel across every health region
additional vaccine sites and mobile
units will be set up and opening hours
will be extended so clinics can run
seven days a week with more early
morning evening and weekend appointments
that is a massive massive
target and there needs to be a lot of
planning and a lot of support on the
ground for the people at the front line
delivering those vaccines more than 23
million people have already received
their booster jab but this new target of
booking an appointment for every
eligible adult over 18 before the end of
2021 puts the pressure on an nhs already
battling a backlog
we want to do our very very best to
minimise any elective disruption can we
say that we won't cancel anything i
don't think we can say and give that
guarantee and despite being urged to do
so by the government those trying to
book a booster jab online were greeted
with a broken website
long queues stretched outside walk-in
clinics
and lateral flow testing kits were
temporarily unavailable to order from
the government's website
the government is gambling on an
approach that for now prioritizes jabs
in arms over restrictions on our
personal freedom but that is not a
luxury that every nation around the
world enjoys
and that's a problem for the uk
as well as other countries ninety
percent
of people in africa
have no access to vaccines
when in the rich countries
you are already going for your
third job
that concerns us a lot
wealthy nations have administered more
than 17 times the amount of vaccines as
the poorest
the uk has secured early access to
almost 340 million doses of the most
promising vaccines so this problem is
only going to get worse with only some
of the world protected the virus will
still be out there mutating perhaps
pushing an end to the pandemic further
out of reach
you